hey steve
hey how are you doing i'm good
nice to see you
nice to see you i'm gonna join the
chorus of everyone who's coming to talk
to you today and say
wow that your performance is fantastic
thanks steve that's uh
thank you
it was you know i remember you were one
of my first interviews i ever had in
sundance do you remember
it was like overtake shelter it was like
a decade ago so yeah thanks
thank you i i do remember and what you
might not remember was
um
i do remember this because and i
remember wanting i remember wanting to
talk to you because i you know you
weren't known yet but you had like five
movies coming up and i'm like oh she's
definitely gonna be somebody like i need
to talk to her
she's booked like five big movies like
this doesn't make sense it doesn't make
any sense and here we are talking about
the eyes of tammy faye
exactly um so uh jumping into why
this project i can only imagine after
wanting to tell this story for so long
what it was like on the last day of
filming when you finally
what was it like for you on that last
day when you're saying goodbye to tammy
or were you sort of like i am so happy
to be done in the makeup chair um this
is good
uh no i was i was definitely sad to say
goodbye to the character
michael showalter was so great and that
he saved
um a lot of the puppet stuff that we
shot for the very last day so you know
we shot mostly in chronological order
when things get quite dark but on the
very last day andrew and i
are playing around with puppets and he's
preaching and i'm singing as susie
moppet and it was so joyful i was very
sad to
say goodbye to this group of people
i've spoken to a lot of actors and some
they they stay in character during the
entire shoot and others can like turn it
off and on at the beginning and end of
the day what is it like for you and was
it any different making this film
i could definitely turn it off and on um
at the end of the day the only thing i
couldn't keep going was like the endless
amounts of energy that she had
she was always like performing so
you know energetically and at a 10 or
beyond a 10 and by the time i'd get home
you know i would do everything i can to
be present for you know with my family
but then i just
i was the second i could get i would
just crash and go to sleep because it
was really it was like pulling from a
well that of energy that i didn't think
was humanly possible
uh i'm always curious how actors get
ready for a big emotional scene or a
very dramatic scene where you know it's
really going to take it out of you and
you have to be present in the moment so
hypothetically speaking if you were
filming something like that on a monday
how can you take me through your process
and like are you thinking about it days
in advance is it the day before that
you're breaking down what you're going
to do like how do you get ready for
something like that
well that's
i was kind of like in that the whole
time because
you know what made her
a
joke and this is what a lot of the
comedy sketch you know tv shows made fun
of her for is that she cried a lot you
know she was very open and um very
vulnerable and she didn't really have a
barrier between her and others so if
someone said something that moved her
she was there with them and she was
emotional and so i kind of had to do
that to play her like just everything i
could to just
be as open as possible um so i wasn't
thinking in terms of like okay i have to
cry on this day i was more of like
um thinking in terms of just constantly
staying as open as i could i mean i did
more for me was the singing the crying i
don't you know
i feel like i if i'm in my head with the
character's journey i don't really need
to put substitutions in i can be in the
head of the character and then just go
where i need to go
but the singing was very stressful for
me and especially the last scene of the
movie because
there's all these extras i get so
embarrassed like being on stage and like
singing in front of people and it was
such an important way that i wanted to
end the film um as almost a tribute to
tammy
that that actually kept me up some
nights
i can't even imagine i gotta end i'm
just gonna say again
yeah it goes very fast i was gonna say
again uh congratulations you really were
spectacular in the movie thank you very
much